yeah welcome to this video playing Cree
won we won hmm ok probably from the US I
played Knight f3 and here's some
thinking hard c5 I could transpose back
to the Sicilian hmm ok come on let's do
that Sicilian is always interesting
right see the night off I haven't played
this against the night off yet I believe
ninety six seven I don't really know
much about that for probably not hmm I
want to play with F form huh very early
night 85 ok I foresaw the plan anyway
and now and no f5 the classical plan
from back back in the day of fishers but
here isn't if b5 hanging now ok hmm this
looks very dangerous to me for black
night be five you move the Queen to wear
be aid
hmm this is a really interesting yeah
i'm checking various various sacrifices
and I'd be five and then taking me six
stuff like that hmm ok i came on i
didn't really I would have why didn't I
play this first I wanted to play night
beehive and then take this was stupid ah
Jesus I didn't really want to move that
ok let's see what the heck what's still
possible in this end this game if i do i
what a shame ok but anyway what is this
plan probably better be seven hmm and I
be five maybe still not behind that I
don't know I'm fishing here I wanted to
play that b5 first and then I just
screwed up screwed up two moves and ok
so he's actually giving me that I think
I should I should take that I'm
preventing castling at the moment Antone
he takes e4 I mean at least the file is
open
the spot on C 3 NB to this this kind of
setup this looks looks a bit tricky yeah
I've got two ponds I get c3 I got three
partying but of course if I says
basically gone in various ways ok so
maybe here trying to provoke him to take
on me too he cannot really take on e for
the show before yeah it should be foiled
start dreadful really probably due to
rookie one rook f6 is not a problem
because of ruka d1 made yeah or this one
how to react to that can give the trick
on a form or just take it I don't know
take it and e5 don't don't don't know
yeah maybe keep the Queen's on the board
for mode
rook c8 down hmm youxian
yes he was threatening the mate on g2
take here so its own yeah it's not
enough for a piece of course maybe I'm
there still some fight in it and he
doesn't have so many points left the
others p sacrifice was really nonsense
in this form at least maybe I'm there
was some other way to make it work but
in this way it did was simply simply not
working cancer get a check in here but
then the check isn't really helping him
I don't want him to go to d2 it's really
on something to avoid yeah I only have
one corner for this for this piece
yeah what a shame only hope is that it's
just he just has three pawns left and
this Bishop at night you never know if
they can can we actually meet with
bishop at night but of course it's just
reasonable yeah this piece egg was
really nonsense probably the way I
originally intended to play was also
nonsense but it at least I believe it
would have been a bit more interesting
that's if you play on a little bit maybe
I get the a6 porn some somehow don't
really know how but this would be a
little bit of a fight at least don't be
five kill his own just
check
where you can play Knight f6 this is a
valid move shouldn't play b5 pre-move
check yeah how do I even protect you too
after that nonsense I could have at
least play look F to time morning Jeff
check check check check check yeah
unfortunately it's not a real test
because I am so down on time oops this
is actually yeah I just a just a very
bad game I'd like to check quickly if
this this other piece egg the way I
played it was really really nonsense but
then i'd like to see if the other piece
I girls at least a bit bit dangerous
here this is just a yeah finger fella
this was what's the idea maybe it's
completed you're completely a bad as
well I'm not sure Quinn moose and then I
wanted to take the idea that after this
the queen is misplaced and I can take
here but he can actually just retake him
I thought queen age five but he can even
play this and there's no real attack now
probably am it's simply not working and
after before yeah i don't know i played
this takes jack
yeah I was back in the game so quite
clear but not sure how much they are
cases this is not working the computer
actually wants to take with the Queen
which is quite funny intending 97 and
almost made but this is still it's still
good for black or not okay that's not so
bad for what yeah there was some ideas
but basically I screwed up this opening
yeah thanks for watching anyway